I need really big buckets
what who shush - who's shush - who are
you sashing which side well that's a lot
of people out there that are human
beings they deserve respect I'm sorry
he's just you the way you test children
and my opinion you're adults
feel the burn I'm sick of sick of the
young people being sober by guys like
this to live in a house on a hill with
their head set their gold-plated head
set and act like they don't have to care
about you guys so no no shush you do
what you have to do you know they have
to tip student debts the income gap in
this country is ridiculous and then they
they work for nothing which is I'd
oppose since the beginning but no one
listens to Conan Conan
well they toil away Whole Foods to buy
me organic carrots
who needs organic carrots I don't even
ask for them in green yoga tea I'm with
you guys this is ridiculous
boom okay yeah thank you thank you thank
you
let's March straight to his ah yeah I
don't know hearts to your aw I don't
know who's running this a piece of [ __ ]
anyway I'm on your side and I'm working
behind the scenes to make things very
different not for you but for your
children's children
[Music]
you